those are all very helpful because we can see as we start you know ascending
or um as we start ascending as we're levitating um as we start assessing
dude this is not the week for this topic though it really is not man i i have had i've had some
problems with some programs this week oh that's not good to hear yeah i i um so i'm participating
in the uh you know in the ambassador world cup you know we we did all right our team did
so so i think i think we'll make it through we'll see but um i had i had a crit this week go internal
dupe on and it was a crit that had been there for a while on an external surface and i'm like
come on man this is like a competition front this is a competition you know program and they still had
that that dupe in place from for a while back so i'm a little bit salty at the programs this this
this week so hopefully we can still i can still bring an unbiased perspective into this episode
on how to determine if a program is good or not dang that's super frustrating i've actually i i have i
don't know if this is a popular opinion but my opinion is that if something is an internal dupe
and it's still open after like i don't know set your arbitrary time frame six months a year you should
just pay for it anyways because absolutely by that point what an attacker is going to exploit that
right nothing is going to stop an attacker this bug has been there for five years joel okay five
six months i know i know i'm a little salty i'm a little salty we're working it we're working it
through i'm not going to call the program out but um yeah you can roast them you can tell me their name
after after i'll tell you all fair all right let's let's get to the news um let's see what do we got
today okay so i just wanted to do a little shout out real quick jason came on the show last week it
was super fun having him on um he actually released a tool uh almost right as we aired last week or a
little bit before we recorded i think um called aws scrape which is a go tool to um monitor aws ip
ranges and alert for ssl certificate data so this is going to be really cool if you're sorry i just
slapped my mic um this is going to be really cool if you are um you know searching for assets that are
kind of ephemeral or are kind of just popping up and so that you can be uh right get jump right on
attacking them as soon as they pop up i used to do this a lot i kind of edged out of the recon game
but totally viable strategy in my opinion yeah i feel like this is kind of towing a good line between
just like an off-the-shelf tool and a custom home bill like recon continuous checking type
framework where you could probably spin this into something pretty easy to help you get a little
more visibility especially for say you're targeting a specific program which we'll talk about a little
bit later but if you're targeting like one specific program and you want to like continuously get alerts
when they have new infrastructure pop up it's probably a really good way to do it yeah yeah for sure so
definitely be uh you know keep that in mind if you're getting ready to look at um uh you know
implementing something like that for ssl certificates in your recon flow um you want to take let's talk
about yeah a crop lifts so that was kind of the big news over the last week or two that was nuts dude
yeah so basically there was a vulnerability within the google pixel screenshotting cropping mechanism
where if you ever wondered how you can edit an image from your photos app and then there's a revert
button that manages to magically revert it back to its original state well this is kind of how that
works and this is abusing that functionality essentially so they figured out that truncated to
the end of the image is essentially a lot of the original image data then you can use that to
reconstruct it back to the original image to view the full uncropped data so if you took a screenshot of
a sensitive page with a bunch of information on you crop it down to just the little relevant part
you would be able to reverse that back um and then a couple days later they found that the windows
snipping tool is also vulnerable to the same type yeah so it was a it was a zero day in uh in the pixel
stuff and then somebody replied and was like hey it was interesting i i took a screenshot with the
snipping tool and it looks like it has a lot of that same data on the end you might want to look
into that does it do you know if it's like is this the exact same process or is it just like the
snipping tool also sort of made that similar mistake in embedding that metadata it seems like it's almost
identical based on what um the the researcher uh what was what was his name yeah look at this crop yeah
so based on what the research the researcher david uh buchanan mentioned it seems like it's very very
similar it's just the difference between like rgb and um rgba with like wow transparency dang dude
that's nuts yeah look at this it's almost fully he got a almost fully recovered image out of that
yeah it's super wild so it's a really interesting really dangerous vulnerability especially depending
on the image hosting service that you've used like i think one of the examples was discord where this
doesn't have to do with exif data it's not like they're not stripping metadata this is separate
it's the image file itself has extra data attached to it that you would be able to use to extract the
original image so even if you uploaded like a photo to discord five years ago or whatever that could
potentially that photo could be vulnerable to this and you could extract it so uh it's just something
to be aware of i know that he tweeted out some preventative measures so for example one of the
measures that he suggests is from a server side you could write a filter within your uh your web
you know your web server basically like an nginx uh plugin or something like that that would strip
out the end data so that you're only left with the original image and that would work retroactively
and all that kind of stuff so there are definitely um options if this is something that you like you
or your company might be struggling with but um it's definitely one of those like really gnarly bugs
that is uh gonna have a lot of mess surrounding it that's gonna be kind of hard to clean up yeah man
because any any picture cropped within that you know in the past is out there and there's nothing you
can do to really modify that at this point besides yeah i guess if you're hosting an image you can modify
that by you know actually modifying the file itself and stripping off that data at the end but like
who wants to do that i know it sounds awful it's so wild dude one of the it's funny because on the
original tweet thread somebody replied it was like hey so let's say i've been sending cropped images
from google phones to discord for about uh six years oh no how am i and the like report the like
researchers replied was like well it depends on a few factors but given that there's six years of images
i would guess pretty fucked oh my god dude yeah that's bad i wonder did they um did they report
this to google and did it get a bounty i'm pulling it up right now let's see they did report it to
google that was actually the interesting thing i was looking to see if it got a bounty and i did not
see it at least on the original thread i'm sure they must have gotten one um unless there was some really
s3 on google's on google's internal issue tracker i found it from if you go to the the blog post
excluding acropolis uh and then you click on his his blog at the very end there's like an issue tracker
and then yeah it says fixed uh s3 p3 um but no bounty assigned so i don't know man if they didn't
give a bounty for that that's pretty whack because that's a very impactful bug i think yeah it's super wild
it feels like one of those things that would be worth like you know 30k 50k 100k something like
that one of those really really groundbreaking ones yeah so i do hope that they got a bounty or we'll get
one soon and they might even be eligible that might be one of those things that's eligible for uh
the google play rewards thing oh yeah that's an extra value but yeah really cool bug um it was
really interesting if you haven't given it a read go read the original blog post because it's so
interesting it was another one of those kind of bugs that just popped up out of nowhere like by accident
and they were like i wonder if this is possible and just kind of explored that route and it ended up
being a really bad really critical vulnerability so it's a really interesting story it's a really well
written blog post um and it's a super super interesting vulnerability yeah all together sometimes
you just got to go after that curiosity man you got to feed that curiosity because sometimes it works
it works itself into some crazy vulns like this one yeah cool uh speaking of vulns in really bad
like really critical core modules you want to talk about the ssrf that doyansec found yeah man that
that was pretty gnarly so uh this was another blog post actually this one came out almost two weeks
ago now but it's i just seen it recently this is a uh ssrf filter bypass in uh node requests
library which is a pretty pretty core library um and so it looks like just from reading this over uh
the tldr of it is essentially if you redirect if you do a redirect to localhost or something like that
when you're using this uh ssrf request filter plugin um and in that request is the same um uses the same
scheme so http website to http website then it catches it but if you send it to an https website
and originally and then you redirect to an http website then somehow it just bypasses the whole
check and if you look at the code in this in this blog dude look at this it's just oh my gosh it's
ridiculous request you write protocols yeah and then it literally just skips the whole thing if you don't
have it's just like i'll just delete the agent yeah yeah um so it's kind of nuts this is not something
that i was testing for um let's see first disclosure to maintainer was 20 uh 2022 in december so um if
you know your companies haven't patched this this very well may still be out there um and definitely
something to take a look at and i think this is particularly nasty because like for for example well
i imagine a lot of people just use http for their little like poc redirect server right because no one
really wants to like spin up you know get an ssl certificate especially those people that are doing
sort of cloud first and just kind of spinning up stuff when they need it um a lot of that stuff is
going to be http based i'd imagine and um this is also probably going to have um ssl verification so
it's not like you can just spin up like a temp ssl certificate or anything so definitely something
to be keeping in mind and test with get you know a full https set up on your on your you know testing
callback server and do a redirect from https to http and see if you can bypass some of those http filters
or those um those redirect filters on ssrfs yeah i think as a tester this would be something i would
probably just put in my normal testing criteria for from a exploitability perspective it does seem like
it has just like basically one mitigating factor which is that the root is through this agent thing
and i hadn't actually heard about i i wasn't familiar with what the agent was or what it was
used for and it looks like it's essentially a way for you to manage connections within like an application
so if you want to reuse connections for more efficiency or that type or if you want to filter
certain connections that was the example that was given then you could do it with an agent and so
basically when it changes protocols it deletes the agent and so all of your checks that might be within
your agent get bypassed so if you're a hacker and you don't know like are they using an agent or not
give it a test and if you're a company and you're not sure if you're vulnerable just look and see if
you're using an agent and if you're not you're probably okay but if you can upgrade just do it
get your get your source code grepping tools ready because yeah that's going to be pretty bad i think this
would also you know be fixed by a decent patch cycle you know if you if you're patching yourself on a regular
basis um and making sure that these core libraries like request are up to date then you should be fine
too but that doesn't always happen as we know true yeah cool um let's see zdi was the only other thing
that i wanted to talk about dude they had like a crazy so we don't really i guess in my sphere of bug
bounty we're mostly talking about hacker one and bug crowd and integrity and all them um and i i don't hear
us talking about zdi quite as much but every time the competition pops up it's pretty exciting and i
kind of want to go for it at some point like i i've only done hacker one live hacking events i've done a
bug crowd one uh i think maybe i did two bug crowd ones but besides that just hacker one and the zdi
model seems pretty pretty cool um they just kind of give you some targets in advance and you earn these
masters of pwn and uh you know obviously large uh sums of money in conjunction with them and i think a
couple teams actually the tesla was a uh was a target for uh some of these teams and uh synactive and then
one other team uh let's see if i can find it yeah one other teams yeah they they also uh pwned the tesla
which is kind of nuts um and i think they walked away with 250k which is crazy yeah super crazy it was
really interesting to see the recap it's cool because uh the re i think the recap was just a
couple days ago and it looks like they paid out just over a million dollars man to the teams so all in
all i mean that's up to par even past some of the live hacking events that we've been to um and it's
really awesome to see that kind of research i think we don't talk a lot about zdi because
and i'm not sure how much this is still the case but at least early on they were kind of like the
like black sheep of the bug bounty world where it wasn't really it wasn't like official like
you're not reporting it directly to the company and stuff right take a look at their website it seems
like they're more like legit and stuff but it is still kind of a weird profit incentive to think about
like basically you're selling the vulnerability to the cdi and then they're going to work with
the vendor and stuff to help like disclose it but they still have that bug in the middle and it's a
little bit a little bit interesting to think about what they might be doing with that bug if anything
all that kind of stuff i'm not going to speculate too much but you can probably use your imagination
yeah yeah no absolutely and you know i hope the sponsors are involved you know straight from the
beginning you know straight from when the reports come in um one of the other things that i've heard
about zdi which is a little bit interesting is you have a five minute slot so these are fully formed
exploits let me just let me just say that as well and these are not normally like i mean sometimes they
have like you know hit this web endpoint and get an rc uh exploits but a lot of the times when you see
the the write-ups for them they're talking about you know binary exploitation stuff um and one of the
so you and i you know you remember when we were working on that bug that we still haven't talked about but
it took a couple minutes but then it took over the whole device right right so i was researching
because that because i was like all right you know this this device had been a target for zdi in the
past and i was like oh wouldn't it be cool if we could have done it at the at the event i was researching
a little bit and one of the things that it i found was that when you're demoing your bug for the
competition for the pontone competition the exploit has to successfully trigger in a five-minute window
which is pretty freaking short and sounds hella stressful because like if you're if you're doing like
race conditions if you're doing you know any of these uh complex attacks that we've been talking
about with like brute forcing that might take a little bit of time but you pwn the device in the end
you know those might not be eligible for this attack or for this you know for this bounty through zdi
um and yeah i think that's a little bit unfortunate because you know i think there's going to be some
there's some good bugs they're missing out on on that yeah it's really interesting i think it's
kind of cool that it's it's sort of a culmination like it you have to perform well right it's not just
having the cool bug you also it also has to work basically basically first time right it has to be
a perfectly executed exploit chain and i assume you have to do this on like a brand new device right so
they bring in like a brand new motherboard or whatever from the tesla and they're like sure
exploit this and you just hope that your testing device was on the same version and then everything
works the same and all that kind of stuff because if it doesn't then there goes your 250k yeah for
sure and i'm looking through here it says on one of their tweets from march 24th his star labs team
was not able to get their exploit on microsoft teams working in the allotted amount of time and
i'm like oh that's got to kill that's got to be so and i'm sure they all went back to the lab and
got it working in five minutes i know and you know we we complain about dupes and stuff like that but
like this guy is literally you know they have this fully formed exploit and then it just you know
something messes up and and they couldn't get it and for five minutes and now that cost goes to much
lower i'm sure their prize goes to much lower so kind of unfortunate but it still looks like a fun
thing i'm not sure i would go all at it and like try to hit all these different devices that they're
doing but um i would definitely definitely take a stab at some of the hardware devices because
we've been focusing on that a little bit more lately and that's been that's been really fun so yeah for
sure all right um let's see where do we want to go from here we can dive right into yeah let's dive
right into it okay so first let's we're so our topic for today is how to determine if a program is
a good is a good program um i think this is going to help people when you're starting out in bug bounty
you're not exactly um familiar with what uh indicators you should look for in a good program
so joel and i are going to talk about some of the things we look at when we look at a bounty brief
and kind of talk through what it means for us to be uh sort of a good program so um joel i'm gonna put
you on the spot man hit me with some of your top program i guess well i guess we can't because they're
going to be private programs in there too can you talk about any of your top you know your top
favorite programs i'm gonna go check if one of mine's is sure and i'll just preface by like most of
them are in the world cup right now but um yahoo uh shopify um those are probably my top two and then
i don't know if i can list the third one because it's a private program so yeah um yeah those are
probably my top two and i'll say the main reasons at least like right off the top of my head we'll go
into these but it's uh how easy it is and how adaptable they are towards like actual hackers
hacking on their program for example preceding accounts letting you sign up with we are hacker one
that kind of stuff yeah and just ability to triage ability to have good payouts ability to
handle things in an efficient manner manner ability to um have a wide enough scope for you to stay
interested for long periods of time like those things are kind of difficult it's not i i'm phrasing
it as ability to right but it's not really an ability it's like do you have lots of servers yes or
no it's right nothing there's no like inherent ability that you have lots of servers yeah no that that
makes sense those are definitely some top indicators for me i've got instacart and paypal on my list i
really like those two programs the third one i would really like to shout out but it's a private program
um i'm just gonna say it's a big bank and they have a responsible disclosure program on hacker one
and yeah they just you know really you know cool i'm trying to think of some you know inverted way to
tell you who it is but let's just say they're the one that i want to hack on okay yeah oh subtle oh okay
i i didn't say anything i can't be held liable um so so um yeah those are my top three and i'll i'll
i'll double click into that for just a second so instacart um has been a really good program to me
um i'm gonna go pull up my you know their their uh page really quick and kind of talk through some
of the reasons why that's the case um first of all the bounty ranges are really competitive so if you
pull up their brief um insta or hackerone.com slash instacart um 20k crits 7 500 highs 3k mediums
500 lows um obviously these are so this is something i'll point out that maybe a lot of newcomers would
miss when you see these numbers it says right underneath there payouts are our typical maximum
for a submission based on severity so just because it says 3k for a medium doesn't mean you're going to
get 3k for a medium you could get 501 dollars for a medium because that's the range between low and
medium um so i want to keep that in mind uh but also um the instacart team has been very responsive
um very willing to uh you know pay good bounties based off of uh impact assessment that i've kind of
talked through with them um and i think that's really important in a program yeah and i think that
highlights a lot of the same things that i talked about where like when you're hacking on something
long term and a lot you want a good working relationship with the program essentially right
so you want to be able to communicate with them efficiently you want them to appreciate the work
that you're putting in as much as the work that they're putting in to fix it right yeah and talk
with you and have payouts and maintain a report and all that kind of stuff um it takes effort from both
sides and so i think when there's sort of that mutual respect from both the program and the hacker
that adds a lot of value to your hacking experience yeah yeah i think that means and and i
think that mutual respect can be shown a lot of ways it can be respect for each other's time
by responding quickly to you know uh responses on the report it can be communicating in a professional
way um so many times you see the uh what is it bloody taxi driver report kind of pop up in in hacker one
circles where somebody just totally went off on on an uber driver or on an uber uh on an uber program
calling them bloody taxi driver um but you know we don't want to be abusive with our words that's never
going to get you a bounty i've never seen someone coming in there saying listen here you guys like
you better beepity beepity pay me some money you know and then get paid so um definitely you know keeping
you know keeping that communication clean and professional and and for me i also struggle with
keeping it concise you know like i often will just be like you know type any type and and you know pop
out this whole list but then i'll just delete it and i'll go back and i'll like look i could i could
accomplish this in like three sentences so i just need to keep it clean keep it smooth and um and i think
that does a lot for the relationship with the program too because they've got a lot of reports they're
responding to and uh yeah that's you know that's a big burden on them if they have to read you know
a novel every time you send in a report so yeah i think that's i think we talked a little bit in in
an earlier episode about report writing but that's one of those things where you don't want to be too
verbose early on when you're new to bug bounty i think it's very easy to feel like you need to fully
explain like every little part like how you got there and what your thought process was and stuff
and it it makes for a cool blog post or it makes for like a fun reading for reading the report like
in retrospect but i think it's better to just be clear and concise to the point and describe the
vulnerability less than the thought process so that they can just be like okay this is what's going on
and understand it really easily instead of having to read through like blocks and blocks of text
yeah yeah for sure so so joel let's let's put put this in a hypothetical here uh i'm gonna send you
i can send you right now on on on discord you can come look at the uh the instacart um team bounty
brief um cool look at that and tell me how you read this what are the things you you look at right away
what things stands out to you um where do your eyes jump when you look at this brief yeah sure so i mean
the first thing i'm looking at is uh the bounty table and like you said is it mins or maxes and
generally speaking what it what is their feeling for highs and crits that i think that's the most
important thing how much money are they putting where their mouth is in terms of high and critical
vulnerabilities are they willing to willing to pay fifty thousand dollars are they willing to pay five
thousand dollars are they willing to pay five hundred dollars they're willing to pay fifty
dollars right like we've seen all across the board like i think one of our buddies just the other day
was just saying oh i just got added to this program and they pay fifty dollar highs and a hundred oh my
gosh dude it was like crazy yeah you know yeah i understand every every company's not just rolling in
money and stuff but that feels like a little bit of a low priority on your security if you ask me
especially when you're trying to incentivize people to spend time finding security vulnerabilities on
your on your company yeah and and valid you know validated um poc or gtfo vulnerabilities because
you know if you're just going to pay and i think we've had some programs in the past do that if you
read through the activity if you're going to pay everybody who submits a report like hey you missed
these headers uh hey you know spf record bloody blah dmar whatever um then you're you know one you're
incentivizing bad behavior in the bug bounty community because those reports don't get um
accepted elsewhere so people are going to submit one report get a 50 bounty from you and then get
screwed for the rest of their bug bounty career um uh but also you know you're going to get a bunch of
you know crappy no poc bugs and at the end of the day that's not what bug bounty is about bug bounty is
about handing them i this is my opinion maybe but i feel like this is pretty well backed up in the
community but i feel like bug bounty is about you know most of the time handing them an actionable
item that that's going to make changes in their code right away that it oftentimes is uh attached a
you know beautiful poc that's going to demonstrate impact um and and you know prove something that needs
to needs to change so um you know if you if you have these if you have 50 bounties or whatever and you're
just throwing them out like candy to everyone you might be paying the same amount but i think you're
getting a lot less um bang for your buck because you're not attracting the right kind of hackers and
you're incentivizing poor behavior in the bug bounty community right and i feel like if you're paying
$50 because you you realize you have a lot of bones and you don't want to be going broke then
maybe address why you have so many bones like this is one of the cruxes of like a well-paying program
right on one hand it's awesome that they are well paying and that they have high bounties on the
other hand it's kind of terrifying that they're paying so much money for vulnerabilities over and
over again because you should be stopping vulnerabilities absolutely yeah so um anyways
i'll leave that at that we can keep going through so yeah the next thing i'd probably look at is
efficiency i'm basically i read it from top down as you look at it on hacker one or whatever so i'm
looking at the response efficiency section and average time to first response that's a pretty
good metric to see sort of how like how responsive are they how active are they if they have h1 triage
then that metric kind of just doesn't matter because triage will always respond within sla yeah and you
can see up at the top right hand corner just for those of you new to hacker one um if you if you say
you know if you're right next to the smart submit report button if you look to the right of that
it'll tell you when the program launched and also say managed by hacker one if it's managed by hacker
one and and if it is like joel said you're always going to get an sla response from the triagers
um and they're going to be responding within a certain period of time so yeah yeah and i'm glad
that you brought that up the the launch date that's another thing i might even look at that before
the bounty table and stuff but typically i'm going to look at that sort of in conjunction with the
things i'm talking about right here with efficiency and right onto statistics so as i'm looking at
efficiency those things matter sort of but again if it's a managed program generally those things are
going to be kind of within normal normal spec it's probably going to be at least 90 uh hitting sla
over the last 90 days the response times are probably going to be pretty good you know the longer that
you do this i think the less emphasis that i put on like i want a program to have this paid out in
a week or whatever like i understand that things take time i'll submit other bugs hopefully those get paid
out first whatever yeah for sure and i think as a professional bug bounty hunter as a full-time bug
bounty hunter you know there there's this concept of a pipeline too that i've heard a couple other
um bug bounty hunters full-time bounty hunters talk about alex chapman yassine um them um
you know once you once you kind of get rolling you've got unpaid bugs that are you know sitting in the
queue waiting for them to get paid as you're finding new bugs as you're keeping on moving and those bugs are
paying bugs of the past are paying your current expenses and while you're finding the bugs for
next week and the week after that so um a lot of people would say when thinking about full-time bug
bounty like you know i'm sure it's important for you to have like a quick payout it's not really super
important it is important to me from a motivation perspective because you know if i submit a report i
would like to get positive feedback for that report make sure that i'm understanding the threat model
correctly before i invest more time um you know uh researching on that company and developing my
understanding of the threat model even more um i want to know whether i'm on the right path
um so that it is important for that metric but it's not quite important as important for a full-time
bounty hunter as as as pertains to like just getting your normal salary and you know paying your day-to-day
bills yeah but i think that is an important point especially if you are somebody who acts full-time
and you're going to be hacking on one program that's something to definitely consider if they're
going to be paying out fast or slow because how long of a buffer do you need to have reports in their
queue for them to be paying out before you start making money yeah it takes them six months to pay
out a report well then you got to be submitting reports for six months because you got a delay on
that by six months yeah i'm i'm looking at the the instacart um thing here and i believe that this program
has a little bit of a of a delay like the the response you know statistics here it says average
time to bounty is about a month i've actually had a a lot better experience with them than a month it's
normally two two weeks ish for me which i think is pretty good ideally it would be around a week
um but two weeks makes a lot of sense to me um i know they do weekly meetings to pay out their
volumes and assess severity and that sort of thing um so that's that's good um depending on when you
submit it you might hit you know one or one of those or two of those if you submit right before
they do their meeting then you know it might get in that meeting or it might not um so i've definitely
i definitely look at that metric too that's one of the first things that i i look at when i get to a
brief yeah it's it's good to hear like that perspective as well i think it's kind of maybe
something that i take for granted having worked on the other side at companies that have bounty programs
where you know much more how the process is going yeah they're they're a company they have
employees the two other things so generally there's probably a weekly or bi-weekly meeting
where they get together and they talk about the bounties and stuff that's often why there are
delays on bounties because it's a there's it's just a company you know it's being run by employees who
have other things to do it's just a meeting that they go to and they take care of stuff and um as much
as that's your top focus if you're doing a lot of bug bounty it's not always their top focus so you
just have to remember that as you're doing your hacking and you're like where's my bounty yeah for sure so i mean
you've worked with a couple companies that have bug bounty programs is that the normal flow every
week you have a meeting or yeah i mean sometimes depending on the size of the program and how
frequently you get reports you might handle it just sort of ad hoc and right off the bat
i think a lot of companies now are pushing to try and pay on triage so once they basically
validated that it's a valid finding they try and pay the bounty as soon as they can and they realize
they you know recognize okay this is something valid we'll give you your money because we understand the
severity we understand the impact and then we can work on fixing it you can be happy and keep hacking
on us and get your money and hopefully sort of build that rapport between the researcher and the program
yeah i i think shopify was one of the the programs that first brought that into into place yeah it says
if you submit a valid and bounty eligible report we will pay you within seven days of triage um so that's pretty
cool i i would love to see more programs uh you know uh do that because yeah it's definitely motivating and it's also the bigger thing for me is validating my understanding
of of the threat model for the company um and seeing how they respond and how they rate the severity of the bugs so that i can know what areas i need to focus on within the app
yeah 100 percent um cool so generally one of the last things that i look at going back to the the program
like how i look at programs is those program statistics about bounties so i will usually use
that in conjunction with the launch date to understand how old is this program and what are their total
bounties sure and then use that to start doing some of the averages along with the data that's in there so
so for example total bounties paid on instacart right now uh is about 400k the program has been
around for just about a year um it's launched in february 2022 it's uh at it's march 2023 so about 400k in
a year that's honestly a lot of reports for that amount of time um and it says that their average
bounty range is 150 to 250 yeah i think i think that is because of the of the changes to the bounty
table yeah and so i don't know what it looked like before although you could probably step back and
look at it but i try not to take too much of that consideration because that average is across all of
their bounties right yeah of their 400k you can be almost certain that 80 of those are literally just
like bottom of the barrel type low hanging fruit like lows and that's why that average bounty is 150 to 250
because it's not critical things but it they are valid reports if you look at their top bounty range
that's probably what when i would start to be like okay how likely is it that they're going to pay
something really bad and if so what are they paying for it right so that'll typically show like
the very top end of the bounties that they paid if they've ever paid a full max crit which they have
right their body their top bounty range is 2000 to 20 000 so that means they've at least paid a really
bad medium and they've definitely paid a 10 out of 10 critical so that means it's out there and it
exists and they care about it and they put the money where their mouth is and that says a lot yeah i think
also the other thing that the average bounty range kind of says to me as well is if it is on this lower end
uh you know in their low range rather than in their medium range i think this also speaks to the fact
that they are probably a pretty accepting program so you know if you have something that's kind of like
i'm not sure that this is like you know super great you know i have a pretty high standard for for bugs
um and but you know sometimes i'll find something that's just kind of like i'm not sure i i might i
might take a look at this see you know what kind of bounties they're paying and say okay well you
know if their average range is a little bit closer to the low that means there's probably been more
lows accepted so the company might be more willing to pay something that's you know a very minimal
leak in confidentiality or like a very minimal modification in integrity with an attack complexity high or
something like that whereas other programs might sort of just say ah that's not a vulnerability
so that's another you know way you can think through it yeah for sure and i will generally
combine that with the next two things which is bounties in the last 90 days and reports received
in the last 90 days yeah to sort of calculate a second average that's basically a 90-day running average
of roughly how much bounty are they paying now like in the last three months are they actively paying
mostly 150 bounties or they're paying higher than that so in 90 days they paid 22 450 they've resolved
114 reports and their last report was resolved six days ago so that tells me three things one they're
paying pretty good bounties 20k in three months that's not nothing that's a couple thousand a month
that means that there's at least some stuff in there that's worth looking for for sure 100 reports
resolved that's a pretty good amount of activity so just be aware that there's lots of eyes on it and that
means that means a lot of i mean those reports i think also include like things that are in not
just in resolved as in like the state resolved but you know if you put something in duplicate if you
put something in informative you put something in an na so you know think 80 of those are going to be
garbage right because it's a public program so that that can also help skew your statistics for what
actually the bounties look like yeah but if i see like last 90 days total bounties paid like 3 000
that means either their security program their security team is insane yeah they have a small hardened
scope or nobody's hacking yeah so you use some context clues you can probably do some hunting to figure
out which one of those cases it is or maybe it might be something completely different that we didn't
mention but these are generally the types of things that we're getting in like feels from the program
as we're just sort of looking through it and then the last thing that i generally look at is scope
um nowadays it's very common to have broad scope i would say it you know maybe five years ago it most
places would have like one website or like just our main website because there was sort of that fear
over what hackers would do but i think over time the the the community has shifted and realized that it
doesn't really matter what hackers are going to like what bug bounty hunters are going to do because
hackers are going to do whatever the hell they want so you have to have everything in scope otherwise
it doesn't matter if you oh it's out of scope my bad the hackers aren't going to hack us then like
no it doesn't that doesn't matter hackers don't know what scope is they don't care
so i mean sorry non-ethical hackers right we hackers good hackers bad actors yeah sorry bad actor yeah
bad actors are like a scope what's that yeah um so i scope is kind of one of those things that i'll
look at just to see if there's anything really explicitly out of out of scope but generally most
of the things that a company owns oftentimes a wildcard domain or a wildcard subdomain that'll
be in scope and that's always a great sign because it just means that it's free range just
look find a vulnerability and submit a vulnerability um and that that's the main thing that i look for
that's all like surface level if i want to go any deeper than that i might start looking through the
specifics like writings within the program policy to see what things they might have noted down do they
have specific testing procedures do i have to put a header in my requests any of that kind of stuff
that's what i might scan for within the the policy text um but a lot of the times most of the preliminary
data that's going to determine whether or not i'm even going to look at a program is within those couple
of boxes it's yeah what are their rewards what's their efficient response like what are their overall
bounties total and over the last 90 days and how long has the program been out to to sort of gauge
you know what's the what's the payout range look like over a period of time yeah for sure um i i was
actually so i was going to bring up another thing relating to that and i'm not even sure i'm going to
be able to do it right now because i think yeah that's funny bug crowd is going through some scheduled
maintenance as we're recording this right now great timing yeah okay okay no the the cached i can use
the cached version here um so uh man it doesn't have the the data i need though so i was going to talk
about one one program um pinterest on bug crowd uh and kind of talk about uh them as a as an example so
if you look at at their um setup it says that criticals are 25k or up to 25k but then highs are
like and i don't want to quote it wrong since i'm not exactly even looking at it anymore um but i want
to say they were like a couple grand yeah here they are right here i've got it in a screenshot two so p1s
are 20k to 25k and then p2s this is on bug crowd are 2500 to 3500 so like a tenth of a high of a critical
that's quite a quite a range yeah so one of the things that i wanted to talk about relating to this
was i always look at what a program pays for mediums um as well as what they pay for crits because
those are my two main anchor points like the highs okay you know i i do put i do look at that and
it is important but for me the anchor points are mediums and crits because at the end of the day i'm
always trying to find a crit but you know you know how we do here at critical thinking always trying
to find the crits um but at the end of the day when you're finding crits in the process of finding
crits you're going to find a lot of mediums um and and i think it's nice to have a good payout for the
mediums um uh when you know when you're when you're continuing your journey there so um my normal standard
is i want to see the mediums ah man actually before this episode you know i was i've been saying that
i would like to see my mediums at uh 700 at least 750 but with the way that the industry's been moving
lately it might even start you know moving a little bit more towards a thousand um for the mediums that's
kind of where i want to see those you know landing um minimum bunny yeah yeah i mean for minimum would
be would be great the average you know hitting hitting around 750 to a thousand would be good so
if you look at the instacart program you know their mediums are are 3k i had a i had a buddy lately
who submitted a medium and got paid out 2500 and that's that's amazing that's a great you know that's
a great day of hunting right there it was one day uh he's one of my mentees and he he found a great bug
and got a great payout for it um and and so you know i a lot of people get distracted by the big numbers
but at the end of the day you're probably going to find more mediums uh and so if you pay attention to
those uh you'll also walk away with some some extra money in your pocket yeah i totally agree i think
you're more likely to hit on sort of either side of a high where you're either going to find something
that's not quite a high or you're going to find something that is definitely not a high and it's
more of a crit sometimes it'll be on the fence between a high and a crit and that's where i would
emphasize report writing and demonstrating impact and changing vulnerabilities to try and really push it
away from the barrier and really into the critical range but if you know most of the time you're
going to find something that's you know it's a vulnerability it's nothing crazy it's whatever
it's medium or you're gonna find something that's really really bad and is a critical yeah yeah for
sure i totally agree um so let's see i want to go back to this list here because we have a little
list in the doc of of some things here one of the things that you wrote down that i thought was
interesting was like what is the gap between the number one hacker and the number two number three
number four number five hacker what does that tell you about the program yeah so this is something that i
always find really interesting especially for public programs i like 75 of the time it's always like one
of those like top three people who has an insane recon scanning automation yeah system built up like
nagli or try to hack or um or today is new however especially when it's not one of those people that's
when i get really interested because it's somebody who's probably spent a lot of time on that program
they're very familiar they've done the deep dive and they're very very familiar with the inner workings
of that program and their infrastructure and that's what's letting them create that gap right but
something is happening between like top top number one and number two oftentimes it's like a thousand reps
sometimes even more depending on the program and depending on the hacker and i think those are really
interesting cases to figure out what does that person know about the program or what does that person
figured out that lets them get a thousand rep ahead and have so many more crits or highs than the other
people who are hacking and looking at the same scope and how can i replicate that kind of you know either
it's attack methodology or how they're writing the report or whatever so does that does that come across
as see so say you see someone you know 2k rep the next person's like 400 rep or something like that
does that how does that make you feel does that deter you does that encourage you does that
have a neutral impact on your decision to work on that program or what it's a little bit of both
especially if it's somebody i know personally i'm like oh they've already sweeped this program
they found everything but yeah yeah like if it's like you know i don't want to make nick because i don't
want to set that kind of precedent but you know if it's somebody that like i'm familiar with who i like
have a lot of respect for yeah and their hunting skills i would generally probably start to assume
that i'm i'm gonna find like a rare vulnerability if they're like that far ahead but it's also kind
of a challenge right it's like can i find something that they haven't found or i might reach out to
them and ask like what are some of the insights you have about this program see if they're willing to
discuss it maybe work together on something yeah i really like that when i know you know just from
the life hacking scene or just from the hacker scene in general the person that you know really
crushes the program that i'm working on because it's always nice to get their insight and i would
i would say like you know for example the paypal program um they they have some really uh very
active uh top hackers right these guys are i'm just checking right now make sure that i can say i'm
not going to say that yeah so the guy in in first place um you know alex bearson he's phenomenal worked
with him a bunch um yeah okay so joe joe hash is how i'll refer to him uh the guy in second place with
2 300 rep you know both of those guys are legendary at paypal and if you have a question about paypal
they know it you know um but also there's a lot of bugs there i mean clearly they've been finding bugs
consistently for years and and um there's enough space for them there's enough space for for ron there's
enough space for all of the other people on that list as well which means there are bugs to be found
there still um so when i see that i'm a little bit like sometimes i'm a little like if someone if
somebody has a very similar testing file to me for example space raccoon and i would collide on bugs
all the time for a while if space raccoon was like the number one i'd be like yeah but besides that
it's normally like like you said a challenge yeah i also like to look at hacktivity when i see like a top hacker and just see
are they still really active on this program are they submitting a lot of reports um if so
you know are they getting lots of sometimes they have the bounties disclosed sometimes they don't but
are they getting high high bounty payouts that's another good good sort of like testing the water
type thing that you can do where just look in the activity and see if they have bounties um disclosed
on on the reports that they're closing and see roughly you know what are they paying regularly are
they paying out you know some guy is getting three thousand three thousand three thousand has he found
some crazy you know systemic vulnerability that you should be testing for like what is it um but that's
also a really good sort of rough test that you can do to see what's going on at the program yeah i
agree and i and i think you nailed it that that's a positive thing if you're seeing you know these these
these bugs you know coming through because it means that the program will pay if you find the bugs you
know um and that's really the concern here it when you come i think it's a common mistake that beginners
make to come to these programs to be like ah you know i'm going to use eric as an example because he
wouldn't mind you know today's new has like you know 15 000 rep here you know this is crazy i'm never
going to find anything guys eric does predominantly external testing if you log in if you pass the login
screen you've probably seen more of that app than eric has and so like and that's his thing and he
crushes it and he finds amazing bugs on so many different targets but he doesn't look internally so you
know if you see today's new that i i remember actually pretty clearly a time on a tweet where
some you know some new person newer to bug bounty says tweeted out something like when you get a
new private program invite and then you see this and it's like a picture of eric at number one with
like you know however many rep i was like no bro you're just don't pass on that invite like
just that just means i have lots of dangling domains don't worry about it exactly just log into
the app you know like so i think that's i think that's a common misconception that hopefully we've
cleared up here um yeah and i i like one of the things about the hacktivity that i really like
on bug crowd specifically is that in their disclosed things separate from the the bounty they also talk a
little bit about what part of the scope the reports on so you can get a rough idea for where are people
looking where are the bugs servicing themselves is it in the api is it in the front end is it on the
mobile app is like wherever was that a crowd or was that cynac i think it's but i think they actually
both do it oh do they know cynac does it as well cynac even i think they disclose part of the report
title or something like that really okay yeah but but bug crowd will basically just say like in this
scope they got this bounty or actually i think they just say like what what severity it was i don't even
know if they say the bounty but regardless it's just a little more information that will help you
gleam sort of where you might want to focus or not focus depending on what you're seeing yeah for sure
and and i actually or yeah here it is i had something in the doc as well so the known issues tab
is really cool on bug crowd as well i really wish hacker one would implement something like this where
there's a little bit transparency on how many unique issues there are outstanding that have not been
resolved yet in the in the program because one of the things that i really want to know when i come
into a program is like hey are you fixing bugs you know what are the chances of me coming in here and
finding a dupe like i did this this past week and lost out on a big big payout uh crit because they're
not fixing the bugs um that's really painful for me and even as an experienced bug hunter you know i've
gotten probably at this point hundreds and hundreds of dupes and uh you know uh i guess maybe i've the
pain of it has been a little bit uh you know removed from me for a little while because i haven't had one
that really punched me in the gut lately but this one really took the wind out of me and stopped my
testing for a couple days because i was just really like man you know why why is this happening um
and so you know it definitely happens and you just kind of that's part of the game you got to get up
you got to keep working on it but i think something like this with the known issues um indicator for
hacker one would really add a lot of transparency um to that issue and also force programs to stay on top of
resolving um or else maybe their sla light would go red or something like that yeah i think overall
one of the one of the more positive trends i've seen from programs is that they have
slowly added certain things that are common across either a program policy or a submission process
into the like application itself and what i mean by that is for example
integrity when you submit a bug they have additional fields for like what was your ip address during
testing and like you can you know add customizations and stuff like that into the the actual like
form that the hacker is typing into when they submit a bug and those types of things probably on hacker one
would just be in your report template or something when they go to create a new report and just that
additional little step where it's integrated into the application where it's an extra field
or it's an extra tab or something that you can click like known issues right instead of putting that in
your policy it's a tab on on the program page that says these are the known issues so as a hacker i
don't have to read through each program's policy and decide have they put known issues in their policy
page or have they skipped over that entirely are there things i need to know about instead i can just
click the known issues tab and see what they've listed there absolutely agree having some
standardization for that would be huge and it would also allow you in a lot of cases to
programmatically filter you know where if you're doing the hacking you're you're pretty you're pretty
familiar with apis and how they work and such and so you know there's when you're building out your own
automation or you're you know really searching for a program to to go after having something like
that could help you filter down and in your own automation as well yeah for sure um so anything
that programs can or platforms can do to sort of standardize that type of stuff make it easier to
find the information i know hacker one added a scope tab recently which is a nice little shift so you
don't have to scroll to the bottom and stuff like that yeah i think that's cool the scope tab
how do i feel about the scope tab man i don't know i feel like the scope tab is a little um a little
iffy it's a little weird because like it's helpful and it's nice but then there's also scope in the
policy still and so it's kind of feels like all right i still got to read the whole policy and i
can't just jump right to the scope so i think i think hacker one needs to make the full switch over
if they're going to do it um because that you know now i just have two things to read and one of
them is in in my immediate field of view you know when i get to the page 100 yeah um let me see here
so the other thing one of the other things that i kind of wanted to talk about was uh hunter nice to
haves on a program this is this if a program has this there's a really good chance that they're a good
program to work with so what do i mean by that so um here are some examples i've seen programs drop
treasure maps before which will say like hey these and even if it's not a treasure map
if they just say hey these are our core assets these are the assets that we really care about
um that's really nice to have because it allows you to know okay you know if i pop a crit on
you know www.instacart.com i mean obviously the www is important but like if i pop a crit on
you know okay hold on let's let's look because instacart actually has this this type of section
in there which i really appreciate um just gonna control left for core assets yeah here it is right
here so admin.instacart.com would be a big a big target um they include their shoppers mobile app
very explicitly um and so you know when they have stuff like that it's really helpful for you to be
able to uh focus on the correct targets and you don't have to work as much i talked to you earlier
about the threat model right like you don't have to work as much to figure out the threat model you know
okay if it's in this domain it's probably like you know the golden goose of source you know like this
is the thing they want us to go after and get yeah that was kind of exactly what i was going to say
i think there's definitely two perspectives there's the company side which is like should we really be
emphasizing the things that are really critical for our company publicly and then there's the attacker
side which is this makes it so or the researcher side which makes it so much i keep saying attacker but
yeah i mean it the the terms are ambiguous yeah yeah but it's it's also like how do i make my report
more impactful easier so they're basically drawing the lines and saying here's what you need to do to
make it the most impactful report it's you know customer data or it's this specific website or
whatever it's being able to do this certain thing right and those are great guidelines and guiding
factors for steering your testing in a way that makes it impactful and meaningful the whole time
so if you're testing all of your bugs in a way that's going to give it the most impact you're going
to save yourself the time of having to escalate those bugs later and you're going to get obviously higher
bounties the more that you do that yeah for sure the the other thing that i kind of wanted to point out was
there's some programs that will give you free features for their for their premium and i think
that's great because you know one of the things that we talk about here in the podcast a lot is like
pay the pay the freaking subscription fee right if you if you're going to be hacking an app and there's like
like some section you know where it's like oh pay 50 bucks and get access to like super premium stuff
pay that like like every single time i've done that it has resulted in a bad vault
yep um with without exception really um i have made you know 150 times you know 150x return on investment
from that 50 bucks you know that you put in there because a lot of times they're that extra little piece
of friction is what the step that other researchers aren't willing to take and um is really separating
you from the the critical vulnerabilities there but another step that the researchers often don't take
which is also you know a differentiating factor is doing what is required to get access to these test
features through the companies a lot of times which is send the company an email and say hey could i
please have a premium account and if you do that and they say yes and they give you the premium account
well you just saved yourself 150 bucks or whatever it costs and you also got access to the premium feature
so i wanted to shout out another one of my my favorite programs semrush this is a um this is a program
that does um search engine optimization uh it's a search engine optimization application their bounties
are pretty good i normally like to see highs or uh crits uh crits in the five figure range um and highs a
little bit higher than they do but their mediums are are spot on and they're they're pretty um willing
to give out mediums um so they will they will if you you know reach out to them give you a premium
account to test the app with um so definitely keep that in mind uh when you're when you're looking at
that program i'm not even sure they say it in their policy anymore yeah that's pretty that's
actually a really cool approach i don't think i've ever i've ever done that wherever like approach them
directly because most of the time i assume that they'll never give me it but that's a that's something
i'm gonna have to try because uh i kind of like that approach um i think kind of tangentially attached
to that is if you see programs that auto seed test accounts um like shopify for example is great great
example where if you sign up with an at we are hacker one dot com email they precede your account
with like test data they i think they mark it in the back end somehow to make it have like phenomenal
yeah i mean however they do it it it shows that they care right it shows that they have gone the
extra mile they've worked with their engineering team they've made explicit efforts to integrate bug
bounty into the engineering workflow to make it so that you can do testing easier without as many
hurdles and find better bugs and that shows a lot right it shows that even like even though they
might have to pay more money that's fine they'd rather have the security and pay more money than
not have the security or make it harder so that's just like a really awesome thing to see yeah absolutely
and i did find the the um the section in the semrush uh uh policy it's down at the bottom promo code
they'll give you a promo code with a valid submission which i think is a good i think that's a really good
sort of indicator as well you know i feel like they they you know if you're just giving out free
accounts to everybody then it might invalidate your business model a little bit that almost becomes a
bone itself there but if you do it with a valid report submission it proves that the researcher is
actually putting time into the program and has earned you know an account and uh so yeah very innovative
there really liked to see that with semrush cool um what are some of the things going off the off
our list again what are some of the things that um like you look for if you're hacking uh if you're
going back to a target are you looking for like new scope um if they're in the news like what types of
stuff you look for yeah i think you know i often have with the live hacking event circuit i have to
leave instacart and go and and spend time on different programs and then come back to it and
sometimes other programs kind of steal my attention away for a little bit but oftentimes i revert back
to instacart um and in the meantime i you know i'll be looking one of the things that's really cool is
gao has a feature where you can kind of look at recent urls that were indexed so i'll use that sometimes
to kind of you know sniff out new features i'll look like you like you very sure we mentioned in
the news for new features like ah you know instacart just launched xyz and then kind of go after that
um but i'll also go back to the places where i was familiar with where i you know dug in deep the
last time i hacked there and you know i feel like your mind will kind of look at that and be like hey
that's a little bit different than it was before and you know then you start to see like okay this is
sort of a new feature added on here and i've had that happen a couple times where you know just your
your eye from having tested that extensively um is is trained to know where that new stuff is is and
and kind of get attracted to that new functionality so that's kind of that's kind of where i look
it's really awesome to hear like that that perspective that there are like those kind of
stable programs that you can just keep going back to and and enjoy hacking and find new bugs because
i think it's it's a common misconception that if you do too like too much hacking so to speak on one
program that is going to dry up and it can happen but it depends on the program it's about finding
a good program right it's just kind of what we're talking about and finding one that you can hack long
term on and keep finding good bugs keep providing value to the company keep having an enjoyable time
making money provide a living all that kind of stuff yeah for sure i i i almost want to disagree with you
there that that it's about the program i think in some cases it is about the program like if their
development cycle is like they push new features like once every quarter or like you know once every
half year or something like that that it can be absolutely about the program but a lot of the time
man i think it's about people getting complacent and saying like you know you go in there and you like
pwn some stuff and you find a crate and a couple highs and mediums and blah blah and then you like sit
there and you're like oh all right that program's done you know but that's a mistake you know you're
just getting you're just starting to understand the mistakes that the vulnerabilities you know that are
there the mistakes that this company is making and if you dive in again and you go deeper and deeper and
deeper and start trying these same techniques you know maybe an id or worked in a specific type of
endpoint well great you know let's let's try to find other endpoints that sort of resemble this
um you know do they have path traversal issues do they have caching issues these are all things that
can be you know systemic across the the programs and can be a continuous source of bugs especially
idors and access control issues um you know those are those are big if a company doesn't have that
figured out you know with middleware or with something like that then there's definitely a
big potential for reoccurring bugs there yeah yeah that's a great observation it's nice to hear that
like you know sometimes it is a program but it's also you you know like just yeah you don't don't
let yourself slack right yeah all right we are at an hour two let's see um let's see if there's anything
else that wanted to hit oh the other cool thing that i wanted to just go ahead and give a shout out for
two two things here ssrf sheriff and somebody i know has a pretty cool github repo about that right
i know yeah i couldn't imagine who that oh hey it's this guy named techno genius yeah genius love that
guy so um a little self promo here while i was at uber um for one of our live hacking events we wrote
this thing called an ssrf sheriff it was an idea originally um proposed by franz and essentially what
it was is an internal service that's designed to make testing ssrf easier so it's something that you would
spin up within your infrastructure from a company side and you would provide the researchers with an
internal ip address host name all of the above hopefully both hopefully both and it responds to
basically any type of request so it'll respond to images with various various different images usually
with a secret identifier that is within the image um it responds with that identifier in headers in the
body it has different mime types and the whole reason for this is that basically it's designed to
adapt to any ssrf situation if you have basically anything but a blind ssrf and you can see the response
in any way whether that's an image whether that's uh the headers whether that's whatever the goal is
that can i hit this service and if so i should be able to get this secret string back that will prove
definitively that i have an ssrf right if you can provide that secret string to the the program you
can say here's your secret string bam that's it no questions asked the poc or gtfo mentality once again
here is like if you can hit that and and you get this back then boom you know and that that really that
instant feedback for us as hackers as well is really valuable because you know we could spend hours
sitting there poking out with an uh you know blind a scissor of trying to prove internal impact or you
could set up the server we could hit it in in two minutes and have that sort of decided so i love to
see when programs set up that that tool that that joel made it's pretty easy to set up really simple
you just you know if you've got sort of devops in your organization you can you can spin it up real
easily um and definitely something that adds a lot of value okay the other thing that i wanted to shoot
out uh before we before we move along is documentation and you know i love document you
i love you a good document man um and so or a bad one yeah i mean you know bad documentation too it's
better than no documentation and most of the most websites do have documentation um what's better is
when they give you sort of internal documentation documentation for their api and maybe stuff that
contains like graphql schemas or or you know maybe like a postman file or like you know swagger or
something like that um that those are all very helpful because we can see as we start you know ascending
or um as we start ascending as we're levitating um as we start assessing the application um you know you
you start finding um i can feel myself rising off my chair already just i'm stuck on the joel cut it out
man yeah as you start assessing the application you get various you know you see various common threads
across across across the app and um it's easier to see all of those you know when you've got the api
documentation you can see okay well maybe um you know api calls that are structured a little bit like
this would be more vulnerable than others so very very helpful there and it also helps us be thorough as
well you know sometimes you just sit down and you grind and you just make uh you know a replay tab
or a repeater tab for every single api endpoint that you have and you you know fuzz the crap out of
those and that's the kind of testing you want from the program side that's what you know really gets
you some very thorough results um and and so you can really enable that with a swagger file or graphql schema
yeah and this is reminding me of something this is probably more specific to live hacking events
i feel like this fell off a little bit but when i was at uber one of the things that
i pushed for was providing zone files to researchers yeah and um this is a little bit trickier to do for
a public program to keep it like maintained and up to date um there actually was i don't remember
i think that uber does this now i don't know if they do it publicly but but they basically we
created a tool that would automatically pull like a list of all the domains and then keep it in an in a
file up to date so that there's no question about like am i missing something because my recon's bad
or my word list is bad we will give you a full list of every single domain that exists go ahead and find
bugs on it and that removes just you know another barrier it makes it much easier yeah and it shows
that you know security is valued it doesn't matter if it's like a complicated domain we care about the
vulnerability within that domain let's let's see what you got um and sort of just you know again
putting money where your mouth is absolutely yeah i totally dig that too that really puts everyone on an
equal playing field as far as recon goes because you know a lot of people have access to specific i
won't call it out specifically but there's you know certain api services that are out there that are
very very very very very very expensive um that will give you access to a lot more domains than other
people have access to um and and so you know doing something like releasing the zone files puts everyone
an equal playing ground and then it's the it's the person that can hack the app the best that that finds
the bug right and that's kind of like what jason was talking about last week one of my favorite quotes
from last week was you know the whole point of recon is to find more apps to hack you know and and um
uh i think giving giving the zone files really proves that yeah don't make it a recon game make it a security
game you know yeah absolutely um okay cool i think we'll cut the rest of that doc there and uh let me
talk about this report really quick and then we'll we'll peace out so um i just wanted to i i wanted to
talk about this report on the pod because i i thought this was really creative and this actually wasn't
something that i'd seen before or at least i hadn't seen it in a while um this is report 1861974 we'll
link it in the in the description of the podcast but it's a um report uh to pixiv which is a a japanese
program i've actually looked at them a lot because their their site is in japanese um and uh this is a
in this report essentially and i missed this bug just to be clear which makes me a little salty
um but there's an oauth flow and what happens is when the user completes the oauth flow um there's
actually or in the return url there's a path traversal that you can do that allows you to hit
any endpoint on the uh you know target domain right it's only validating you know hey does it start with
blah blah right so in this in the in the example here they have slash off slash pixiv slash callback
and then that's you know where the cutoff ends there and then he is able to do dot dot slash dot
slash dot dot slash dot dot slash and then provide a different item number now this used to be a lot
more impactful um when uh the browsers were sharing the the referrer cross origin um and you could just
you know leak the uh oauth token via a open redirect or something like that then the browser stopped adding
the path and the query parameter to the referrer because of security issues and that fixed a lot of
these issues but the uh the report writer here has a really innovative um solution he uh there's some
uh application there's some feature in the application where you can set up a google analytics
tracking id on that page isn't this cool this is cool right um and when you put up your google
analytics tracking id on there so you can get analytics on how many people are visiting your items
or whatever um what that does is it takes the url and it leaks it to the attacker so i think this is
going to be and you know franz already talks about this in his post message um uh you know expose i
don't like very long thing that he released on on how to leak you know you are oauth urls via post
message um but i think there's also going to be an another area where this becomes you know where
these sort of volms uh essentially uri leak or something like that um becomes a thing because they're
often able to chain with oauth and you often find yourself able to insert or get vulnerable information
into the url and then you know have that leaked if you can find a way to get it out um so it's just
another attack vector for you guys to be thinking about as your as your bug hunting and and um you know
anytime you can leak the ur the url definitely think about oauth tokens or think about sensitive
information getting placed there yeah that's a super creative um like attack scenario i don't think i
probably would have thought that was even possible um but it's like one of those unique application
features that you know the more familiar you are with the application the fact that he knew
or they knew that you could put a google analytics tracking id with your custom google analytics and
yeah track those url that's an awesome like creative way and to exploit this and it was marked as a high
because that you know yeah it's a great finding and i've worked with the pixiv program a little bit like
no i mean i'm not going to diss them but i've had some problems with with them so the fact that they
acknowledged this has a high is really you know one a step in the right direction two shows that how
well written the report is and the mentality of the attacker um which is which is really cool so um kudos to
this guy it definitely this is another rant so i'm going to try to keep it concise because we're getting
you know a little far here but you know you know how we do here we just go and we go and we go um
one of the things that i wanted to talk about is how like in this scenario the attacker realizes the
hacker realizes that uh you know when stuff when sensitive information makes its way into the url
there's risk there when when you know and when user input gets reflected into the the dom or to the
body there's risk there and i think um a lot of the ways that people address learning how to hack is
like oh okay xss you know okay idor and they they think about these vulnerability categories when
in in a lot of times the way that you're coming up with these big brain like crazy creative bugs is you're
not thinking about it so much as from this perspective of like god this is a volume type that i'm familiar
with you're coming at it from this perspective like okay when a application takes attacker information
and puts it in a request that they make on the server side sketchy stuff happens when that data gets
reflected into the dom sketchy stuff happens when sensitive information gets put into the url sketchy
stuff happens and that's you know so as you're as you're starting to learn how to hack those
indicators should start triggering like okay this is weird okay this is sketchy oh there's post messages
flying here that's inter page communication you know there's an attack vector there and i think
focusing on those instead of focusing on vulnerability types can more can help you become more of a of a
i don't want to use the word generic but like a sort of a jack of all traits hacker you know someone
who can really under come that isn't like a textbook hacker that just reads the textbook and finds the
i doors by replacing the number right um so if you're really shooting for the stars um understanding
those threat models in the browser in the app you know in all pieces of the application is really
important i think yeah it's like that more adaptive kind of style of hacking it's not just that
you're you're not a just a scanner right you're not just nessus or whatever you're you're a hacker and
you're you're supposed to be coming up with more creative because those automated systems don't
worry they're out there there's a million of them and they're doing it all at the same time like
that that attack service is almost certainly covered yeah what you should be focusing on is the more
creative things that those scanners are not going to find that are going to provide real deep inherent
value to the security team and to the to the company who's dealing with this vulnerability right it
it shows you know i think this report is a great example of it where it's just showing
that you've gone one step further right like anybody could just test it oh otflow okay it doesn't have
a redirect and if you can it's just on a path okay whatever next done skip right but this researcher
specifically was like hang on a second that is weird that's there is risk right how can i exploit that risk
yeah phenomenal really really well done there um good good tips to end the podcast with uh you got
anything else you want to say before we bounce joel no i think that's it all right sweet that's the pod